اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في كل دقيقه تمر يزداد
السودان اشتعالا يوم سادس من الاشتباكات
شرف على الانتهاء وانتهت معه قبل ساعات
هدنه ثالثه في الحقيقه هي لم تصنع اي فارق
كبير مصادر العربيه اكدت انه لم يتم فتح
مسارات انسانيه بالخرطوم خلال الهدنه
الاخيره التي انقضت وهو الهدف الرئيس اصلا
منها والمتضرر الوحيد بالطبع هو المواطن
السوداني حيث تسقط القذائف والرصاص داخل
منازل المدنيين كما نشاهد وفي وقت يحتفل
فيه الملايين حول العالم ببهجه عيد الفطر
الذي يحل علينا بعد الساعات في السودان لا
بهجه لا تفاوض بين الاطراف المتنازعه ولا
مؤشرات على الحل والاجساؤوا ربما لم ياتي
بعد
صراحه
كل شيء كل شيء كل
ار
فقدان كل
شيء حتى حتى مالي ملابسي
على كل شيء كل شيء في الشقه تدمر تماما هل
لك ان تصف لنا الحادث من بدايته
كنا نعمل
هذا اليوم الامس
في حدود الساعه حوالي الساعه
صباحا
كعادة يعني كموظف
يعني لي خبره في المجال الامني
اخذت كل كل اسرتي الى الصاله الخارجيه لكي
ننام ارضا
من جديد حاله من الذعر والخوف تنتاب
المدنيين في السودان على وقع زخاه الرصاص
والمعارك الكثيفه التي حاصرت مساكنهم رغم
هدنه هشه كاسابقتها ما دفع الالاف لجمع
امتعتهم والمصارعه بالفرار تجنبا لنيران
قوات الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
حاله الذعر لم تقتصر على المواطنين
السودانيين فقط بل امتدت الى الاجانب
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه التي بادرت بعمليه
تنظيم رعاياها تمهيدا لنقلهم خارج السودان
بعدما بدات بالفعل دول مثل المانيا
واليابان خططا لاجلاء مواطنيها لكن من
المؤكد ان الاضرابات المستمره واغلاق
المطارات الرئيسيه ستعيق تلك الخطط مصادر
مطلع افادت بان مهمه الجيش الالماني
لاجلاء نحو 150 المانيه من السودان ارجات
بسبب القتال الدائر في العاصمه الخرطوم
وعدم التزام الطرفي الصراع بالهدنه
الثانيه التي تنتهي مساء اليوم كذلك تحدثت
اليابان عن وجود حوالي 60 مواطنا يابانيا
بينهم موظفون في السفاره بالخرطوم فمع
استمرار اغلاق المطارات تعتبر الامم
المتحده ان خطه الاخلاء الفوري جوا
مستحيلا ما دعا الى النظر في امكانيه
استخدام الطرق البريه رغم المخاطر
الكارثيه التي تحيط بها
حصيله قتل المواجهات متضاربه لكنها تجاوزت
مئات القتلى والاف الجرحى وهي تبقى مرشحه
للارتفاع مع استمرار الصراع بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع في قلب العاصمه
الخرطوم ومناطق اخرى من البلاد
الله اكبر الله اكبر ازمه تركت اثارها على
الجوانب المعيشيه للمواطنين وضاعفت اسعار
المواد الغذائيه حتى المرافق الصحيه لم
تسلم كذلك من تبعات الصراع حيث اجبرت
المستشفيات المرضى على مغادرتها لنقص
امكانيات العلاج والاقامه ومع استمرار
الاشتباكات اصبح من الواضح انه لا يوجد
مكان امن في السودان لحياه المدنيين
منوهه مشاهدينا الى الاخبار العاجله التي
تاتينا عن مبادره القوى الوطنيه
السودانيه والتي تقول بانها ستقدم مبادره
شامله لاطلاق لوقف اطلاق النار والحوار
لحل الخلافات
حضر قيادي بقوى الحريه والتغيير السودانيه
في تصريحات لصحيفه سودانيه من ان استمرار
الحرب سيؤدي الى ما وصفه بتدخل اقليمي
واسع يحاول السودان الى دويلات متناسعه
ونقلت الصحيفه عن القياده بالحريه
والتغيير ياسر عرمان قوله ان الحل الوحيد
في السودان هو تشكيل كتله مدنيه صلبه
ومتحده ضد الحرب مشددا على انه بدون ذلك
ستتمزق البلاد دون رحمه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه انها تراقب
الوضع في السودان مع استمرار المعارك هناك
وتجري تقييما لحالات اجلاء طارئه ويستعد
البانتاجون لارسال عدد اضافيا من الجنود
الى معسكر لمنير التابع للبحريه الامريكيه
في جيبوتي ومن المتوقع ان تعمل القوات على
تامين وربما تسهيل مغادره موظفي السفاره
الامريكيه في الخرطوم اذا اقتدت الظروف
واشارت مصادر الى وجود اتصالات بين وزارات
الخارجيه الامريكيه وطرفي النزاع في
السودان لضمان عمليه الاجلاء
في الاثناء وفي رد على السؤال لمراسل
العربي قالت الناطقه باسم الخارجيه
الفرنسيه ان هناك ضغط دولي للتوصل الى
هدنه في السودان بهدف حمايه المواطنين
والرعايا الاجانب مدام كورونا
اتصلت الوزيره
بنظيرها السعودي وبالامين العام للامم
المتحده من ضمن سلسله اتصالات تقوم بها
فرنسا حول السودان هناك ضغط جماعي للوصول
الى هدنه طوارئ انسانيه ثم وقف اطلاق نار
دائم مما يجب ان يسمح بالخروج من الازمه
يجب ان تسمح الهدنه ايضا بحمايه المدنيين
وخصوصا الرعايه الاجانب ولكن ايضا البعثات
الدبلوماسيه التي استهدف بعضها اتصلت
كولونيا بشركائنا في الجامعه العربيه
ومنظمه ايجاد والاتحاد الافريقي وستجري
اليوم اتصالات جديده مع هذه الاطراف
الثلاثه ومع الامم المتحده وشركائنا في
مجموعه الدول الخمس الدائمه العضويه في
مجلس الامن
اولويتنا المحافظه على امن رعايانا هناك
والذين نطلب منهم عدم الخروج من منازلهم
لان القتال في الخرطوم يجعل اي تجول فيها
امرا خطيرا في هذه المرحله
وينضم الينا من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه
سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك سالم كيف هو الوضع
الان في الخرطوم يعني الاشتباكات لم تتوقف
[موسيقى]
الاستعداد لبعض القضايا اول مشكله تواجههم
هي عدم الوقود في هذه المناطق يريدون وقود
من المحطات المحطات الكثير منها لا تعمل
والتي تعمل فيها صفوف طويله جدا للوصول
الى هذا الوقود كذلك بقيه المحل التجاريه
مغلقه عدا افران الخبز وايضا فيها
صفوف طويله كذلك بقيه المحل مغلقه في
الشوارع الرئيسيه في المحل والمحله
التجاريه هذا في المناطق القريبه من
المناطق التي حولها اشتباكات المناطق
البعيده من هنا تشهد حراكا ربما اكثر
وفيها محل يعني تعمل اكثر كذلك مما اضطر
كثير من المواطنين في هذه المناطق الخروج
الى المناطق التي توجد عليها الحركه وربما
هذا ايضا كثير من المواطنين يعني يرونه
خطرا لانهم لا يعرفون طرقها مستوى الامن
فيها
وتفاصيل هذه القضايا الشائكه في ظل هذه
الظروف الشائكه كذلك السالم كان الوضع غير
جيد وحصلت اشتباكات في الابيض ما هو الوضع
او كيف هو الوضع الان هناك
[موسيقى]
الثقيله والخفيفه من الرصاصه الطائش
والشظائر التي ايضا ضربت بعض البيوت كثير
ممن تواصلنا معهم كذلك تحدثوا عن ان طائشه
دخلت بيوتهم وتفاصيل كثيره تتعلق بهذه
الازمه الحقيقيه بالنسبه للمواطن
سالم هل هناك من يعني معلومات عن توسع
الاشتباكات بالعاصمه الخرطوم لتشمل اكثر
واكثر التجمعات السكانيه المدنيه
نحن هنا في ولايه الخرطوم الاشكال الاول
هو انقطاع التواصل اصلا بشكل كبير هناك
مشكله في الوصول من مدينه لاخرى وهنا نعلم
ان جغرافيا العاصمه الخرطوم مكونه من ثلاث
مدن رئيسيه كما هو معلوم للجميع الخرطوم
وبحري وام درمان هذه الثلاث مدن تربط
بينها جسور كما هو معلوم مع غالب هذه
الجسور مغلقه قاعده بعض الجسور وحتى هذه
الجسور التي تركت او هي يعني يعبر بها
المواطنون بها ايضا قوه عسكريه منتشره
حولها لكن تختلف نسبه الامان من جسر لاخر
بحسب المواطنين الذين يذهبون بهذه الجسور
التي هي محدوده جدا لا تتجاوز الثلاثه
جسور بقيه الجسور كلها خارج الخدمه لا
يمكن ان يمر بها احد اصلا اطلاقا ولان
يقترب منها اصلا يعني حتى مجرد الاقتراب
من هذه الكسور مشكله فمش التواصل هذه التي
تشكل واحده من الازمات الخانقه بالنسبه
لولايه الخرطوم ايضا بالنسبه لمشكله
التواصل هي التي تسبب ايضا بقيه الاشكاليه
التي ترتبط بالامداد باشكاله وانواعه
امداد الوقود الامداد الغذائي بالنسبه
للحركه الطبيعيه كذلك
وربما يعني تجعل من حياه المواطن بالفعل
اشكالا الان مشكله المياه في العديد من
الاحياء في منطقه بحري ما زالت قائمه كما
هي تخرج المواطنين اليوميا للبحث عن
المياه يحملون الاواني بالنسبه للابار
بعض المواطنين الى ان يشربوا هذه المياه
الغير صالحه للشرب كذلك كل هذه الامور
تعقد من المشهد بالاضافه الى
المستشفيات التي تعمل في ايضا في درجات
منخفضه كذلك في استقبال الحالات الطارئه
فقط
كل هذه من الاشكاليات التي يعيشها مواطن
ولايه الخرطه لو اردنا ان ننجز هذا اليوم
اليوم السادس من هذه الاشتباكات المسلحه
كيف يمكن وصفها واين تركزت المعارك تحديدا
اليوم
المعارك منتشره في نقاط معروفه وهذه
النقاط هي الابرز
للاشتباكات دائما معروف محيط القياده
العامه للجيش مطار الخرطوم كذلك منطقه جبر
كذلك شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه كذلك الجهه
الشرقيه من الخرطوم كابوري مثلا
والامتداد في شارع الستين كذلك الى الطائف
في هذه في هذه الشوارع ايضا شهدت مجموعه
من الاشتباكات كذلك اما في منطقه بحريه
تركزت الاشتباكات في كافوري وايضا في كوبر
وكذلك محيط جسر شنبات اي المظلات وكذلك
حله حمد وكل هذه المناطق حدثت فيها
اشتباكات حدث اشتباك كذلك في شارع الانقاذ
ببحري او شارع الشهيد مطر سابقا اسمه
الانقاذ هذا الشارع الذي شهد اشتباكا
عنيفا بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني في هذه المنطقه كانت مواجهه
مباشره في شارع الانقاذ ايضا في ام درمان
شهدت الاشتباكات يمكن ان نلخصها ايضا
بانها في محيط الهيئه العامه للاذاعه
والتلفزيون وايضا في سلاح المهندسين تسمع
ايضا الناريه وتبادل اطلاق النار وايضا
محيط الاذاعه والتلفزيونيه يمتد يعني
مسافته ربما ليس فقط في محيط الاذاعه
والتلفزيون يمتد الى القرب من منطقه
المورده شريط طويل في هذه المنطقه تحدث
العديد من الارتباكات سالم مبادره القوى
الوطنيه السودانيه تحدثت عن تقديم مبادره
الشامله لوقف النار وبانه نتيجه هذه
المساعي ستكون خلال الساعات القادمه هل
هنالك من معلومات توفرت لديكم حول تفاصيل
هذه المبادره
نعم هذه المبادره هي تقدمها القوى الوطنيه
وفيها العديد من
الشخصيات التي وقعت عليها منها ملك عقار
وسعيم الحركه الشعبيه وفضل الله والمناصر
رئيس حزب الامم القومي المكلف جعفر الصادق
المرغني جبريل ابراهيم زعيم
الصادق المهدي احدى قيادات
حزب الامه القومي
الناوي وايضا جمال عنقره مباركه ردول عبد
الرحيم محمد صالح كل هذه الاسماء وقعت على
هذه
المبادره هي مبادره في فكرتها
لوقف العدائيات لاغراض الانسانيه الملحه
ومراعاه الظروف بالنسبه لعيد الفطر
المبارك الذي يعني يبتدئ من يوم غد بمشيئه
الله واصلت المبادره بحسب ما افادت
الموارد بانها تواصلت بقيادات قوات
المسلحه والقيادات قوات الدعم السريع
وحصلت على موافقه مبدئيه من الطرفين لوقف
العدائيات خلال ايام العيد مع بعض
الملاحظات التي تسعى المبادره لحلتها خلال
ساعه القادمه بحسب ما ذكرت المبادره هذه
توطيئه لتقديم مبادره شامله تهدف الى وقف
شامل لاطلاق النار واتخاذ الحوار سبيلا
لمعالجه كافه القضايا والخلافات كل عام
وبلادنا بخير هذا ما ذكرته مبادره في
خطابها شكرا جزيلا لك من الخرطوم مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاش
مي قالت الامم المتحده انما بين 10 الى 20
الف شخص فروا من السودان الى تشاد بسبب
تدهور الوضع الامني الناتج عن الصراع بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم وعبرت الامم
المتحده عن قلقها الشديد من تصاعد العنف
وتطورات الوضع في السودان الذي سيكون له
تاثير سلبي على حياه المواطنين وايضا على
طرق تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه التي اصبحت
صعبه في الفتره الاخيره في الاثناء نشد
الامين العام للامم المتحده اطراف النزاع
في السودان بوقف اطلاق النار داعيا لهدنه
تمتد لثلاثه ايام طوال فتره عيد الفطر
كاولويه فوريه اناشد اطراف النزاع وقف
اطلاق النار لمده ثلاثه ايام على الاقل
احتفالا بعيد الفطر للسماح للمدنيين
بالفرار من مناطق النزاع والبحث عن العلاج
الطبي والامدادات الضروريه الاخرى يجب ان
يتبع ذلك حوار يسمح بالانتقال الناجح
للبدء بتعيين حكومه مدنيه يجب ان يتوقف
القتال فورا انا ايضا قلق للغايه بشان
حاله العديد من الاشخاص العاملين في الامم
المتحده داخل منطقه النزاع
اك
دت ملاحظه للطفوله مقتل ما لا يقل عن تسعه
اطفال واصابه اكثر من 50 اخرين في
الاشتباكات الدائره في السودان واوضح بيان
اليونيسف ان العديد من العائلات في
السودان محاصره بسبب تبادل اطلاق النار
كما اجبر الالاف على مغادره المنازل بحثا
عن مكان امن كما اكدت انها لا يمكنها
تقديم المساعده الانسانيه دون ضمانات
لسلامه موظفيها وفي تصريحات للعربيه اوضح
وزير الصحه السوداني هيثم ابراهيم ان هناك
حاجه لتامين مسارات انسانيه لايصال
المساعدات للمحتاجين ومؤكدا ان مراكز طبيه
تعرضت للحرق الكامله في السودان
محتاجين انه يصل لمواقع المستشفيات كذلك
محتاجين لمساله تامين وصول الكوادر الطبيه
واجازه مسارات لانه برضو هناك عدد من
الكوادر الطبيه تعمل في هذه المستشفيات
خمسه او سته ايام متصله بالليل والنهار
مقدمين العمل الانساني الكبير والجليل
فبالتالي احنا محتاجين لتامين مسارات
الامداد وايصال الوقود للمستشفيات تم
تحديدا بصوره اساسيه كما نحتاج كذلك
كما افدى وزير الصحه السوداني بان
مستشفيات العاصمه الخرطوم الاكثر تاثرا
جراء الاشتباكات مشيرا الى ان انظمه
الكهرباء والمياه لحقتها اضرار كبيره في
ولايه 125 مستشفى ما بين قطاعين العام
والخاص
تاثرت المستشفيات المركزيه بصوره اساسيه
اللي هي فيها النقاط الاشتباك ابي صوره
كبيره في مركز الخصوم والمستشفيات التي
تعرضت الكيبولات الكهرباء للقصف والضرب او
خزانات المياه وصارت فيها صعوبه في
التشغيل
[موسيقى]
الوضع الصحي في السودان على حافه الهاويه
اغلب المستشفيات خارج الخدمه بلغه الارقام
70% من المرافق الصحيه توقفت عن العمل او
اجبرت على ذلك وفق نقابه الاطباء
السودانيين من اصل 74 مستشفى في العاصمه
هو الولايات القريبه من مناطق الاشتباك 52
منها اصبحت خارج الخدمه تماما تسعه
مستشفيات تعرضت للقصف الشديد ما يعني وجود
اثنين وعشرين مستشفى في المنطقه لكنها
مهدده بالاغلاق في اي لحظه هناك حاليا
يعني حوالي 16 مستشفى في عموم السودان
وبالاخص تسعه في الخرطوم خرجت عن الخدمه
بسبب الهجمات العسكريه هناك ما يقارب من
عدد مستشفى مهدده بالتوقف عن العمل بسبب
الارهاق العاملين الصحيين هناك نقص في
توفر الكهرباء والمياه النظيفه
وانضم الينا من مدينه مراووي مراسل
العربيه نزار بقداوي اهلا بك نزار يعني
كيف هو الوضع الان بمروي وهل عادت لو بشكل
جزئي يعني اوجه الحياه الى الاسواق والناس
الى حياتهم الطبيعيه
هذا ما كان مؤمل وهذا ما حدث بالفعل ان
تعود الامور الى طبيعتها ولو بشكل نسبي
ليس بالوضعيه التي كان يعيشها سكان
ومواطنوا مدينه مروي خلال السنوات الماضيه
والاشهر الماضيه وحتى الاسابيع الماضيه
لكن الظرف الذي يعيشه الان مواطنوا منطقه
مروي وعموم سكان البلاد الشماليه هو افضل
بكثير من ما يعيشه سكان مدن كثيره كالبيض
ومدن دارفور ومدن العاصمه المثلثه الخرطوم
ام درمان والخرطوم بحري حاله الهدوء الان
هي التي تسود على قرار ما حدث في قاعده
مروي العسكريه والمطار ايضا حاله من
الهدوء
سكتت الان اصوات المدافع وازيز الطائرات
التي كانت تحلق خلال الايام الماضيه في
اطار الاشتباكات التي دارت رحاها خلال
الثلاثه الماضيه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع لاحكام القبضه بصوره كامله على هذا
المطار هذا ما اكدته القوات المسلحه
السودانيه الجيش بانها بسطت سيطرتها كامله
على كل حدود المطار نحن وصلنا لنتاكد من
هذه التاكيدات وهذه المعلومات وبالفعل
وجدنا ان الجيش هو من يحكم القبضه في
مداخل المطار وفي حدود المطار الشماليه
والجنوبيه والغربيه هذا الامر انعكس
ايجابا على الوضع الانساني والوضع
المجتمعي كثير من الاسر التي كانت رد
اضطرت خلال الايام الماضيه الى مغادر
مدينه مروي الى مناطق اخرى الان تعود وقد
دخلت معظم الاسر ظهور هذا اليوم
في دائره النشاط الاقتص المعتاد ودخلوا
الى سوق المدينه الرئيس
للتبضع ولشرائح احتياجاتهم استعدادا لعيد
الفطر المبارك الذي
سيدخل بعد ساعات من الان الاوضاع هادئه
هنا في مروي الامور مستقره نسبيا الجيش
ينتشر عبر ارتكازات مختلفه
لتامين المنطقه
ومنح المواطنين احساس بان الامور تحت
السيطره هذه هي الصوره التي تنقل لكم من
هذه المدينه مدينه مروي وعموم ارجاء شمال
السودان يعني الاوضاع حول مراوي او بالمدن
المجاوره هل من معلومات عن اشتباكات تحصل
ام ماذا
لا حديث الان هنا في مروي على الاقل او في
كريمه احدى المدن او حتى في المناطق
الجنوبيه الواقعه جنوب محليه عن وجود
لقوات الدعم السريع بعد ان تم التعامل عبر
الطيران العسكري مع اخر مجموعه خرجت من
مطار مروي الدولي التابعه لقوات الدعم
السريع لم نعد نسمع اي حديث عن وجود لقوات
الدعم السريع في محليه مروي حتى شهود
الاعيان من المواطنين الذين نستطلعهم عبر
الهاتف وعبر الافادات الخاصه عن هل ترون
سيارات للدفع الرباعي هل تشاهدون وجود
لقوات الدعم السريع يقولون بانه خلال
اليومين الماضيين مروا عبر الشريط القروي
باتجاه مدينه ام درمان ولا وجود لهم الان
هذه التاكيدات يبدو انها ايضا متطابقه مع
ما يقوله الجيش هنا في مروي بانه الان
يحكم القبضه والسيطره تماما على مداخل
المحليه على مداخل المطار ولا وجود لقوات
الدعم السريعه
النظام من خلال الجولات التي قمت بها ما
هو حجم الدمار في مروي لا اتحدث عن المطار
اتحدث عن
التجمعات السكانيه عن المباني هل تضررت
بشكل كبير ام انه لم تصلها الاشتباكات
بعض الاسر تحديدا الاسر التي تسكن بالقرب
من مطار مروي الدولي هذه الاسر بطبيعه
المنطقه الجغرافيه المتاخمه للمطار تاثر
بعض الشيء وقعت بعض القذائف وبعض الفوارق
المتعلقه بالدانات او بالاسلحه التي
استخدمت في الاشتباكات تاثرت بعض الاسر
الشظايا ايضا تعرض لها مواطنون في هذه
المنطقه تم اسعافهم وعلاجهم بعض
المستودعات المتعلقه بتامين الوقود تاخرت
بعض الشيء لكنه ضرر يظل جزئي هذا فقط هو
ما حدث هنا في هذه المدينه
بقيه المواطنين الان يتحدثون عن استمرار
الهدوء ويرجون ذلك ويتمنون ذلك
الان عن الظهر لحقت بالمدينه سواء كانت
مروي او القرى التي تتاخن مروي جنوبا نحو
العاصمه الخرطوم هذا هو المش
ملامح ما حدث وتداعيات ما حدث في هذه
المدينه وهذه المحليه التي تعد واحده من
محليات الولايه الشماليه التي تمتد لتشمل
محليه كريمه ومحليه ومحليه وادي حلفا
ومحليه البروجينج وعدد من الوحدات
الاداريه المختلفه في هذه الولايه ماذا عن
عوده
هل عوده الكهرباء هل الوقود متوفر المواد
الغذائيه الادويه
لاحظت ايضا خلال تجوالي صباح و الظهر
ومساء هذا اليوم
بان هنالك انتظاما في خدمات الكهرباء
والمياه
هنالك ثلاثه في الحركه داخل مدينه مروي
وداخل القرى المحيطه بمروي بحكم ان مروي
هي السوق الرئيسي في هذه المنطقه كمدينه
سيحتاج اليها المواطنون خاصه في ساعات
المساء لتغطيه احتياجاتهم وهم يقبلون على
عيد الفطر المبارك عليه فان السوق سيكون
مركز الحراك ومركز التحرك
والتجوال بقيه الخدمات متوفره في هذه
المدينه المستشفيات الان تعمل على كفاءه
عامه وكفاءه تامه
الكثير من الخدمات متوفره خدمات الاتصالات
لم تقطع من هذه المدينه
ظلت مستمره حتى خلال ازمه الاشتباكات بين
الجيش والدعم السريعه وضع الان وضع مستقر
هذه نسبيا لا حديث عن ازمه غذاء في هذه
المنطقه
الطرق الثالثه الادويه متوفره لم نلحظ بان
الصيدليات تسكن ادويه او في المعدات
الطبيه حتى الان هذا لم يظهر كمشكله
وظاهره يتحدث عنها المواطنون يشتكون منها
المواطنون محطات الوقود ايضا لاحظت خلال
التجوال وخلال المتحده الى عيب
تمت صفوف في بعض المحطات محطات الوقود في
كل من كريمه المدينه الاخرى المجاوره
لمروي ومدينه مروي بحكم انها ايضا مغلقه
بحكم الظرفيه الامنيه التي كانت تعيشها
المنتقلات عاودت هذه المحطات محطات الوقود
عملها
وبدا المواطنون واصحاب السيارات بالاصطفاف
يتوابير منتظمه حتى ينالوا
حصتهم من الوقود وعليه يتم الامور على
وتيرتها المعتاده شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المعلومات مراسل العربيه نزار تقداوي
حدثنا من مدينه مروي
بعد سته ايام من الاشتباكات المسلحه
والعمليات العسكريه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع كيف تبدو الاوضاع الرهينه داخل
مدينه مروي نحن هنا لنجيب على هذا التساؤل
كان في اغلب الناس رحلوا من المنطقه
وين الحمد لله الليله من الصباح النصر
رجعوا لبيوت ورجعوا للترتيبات والحاجاتهم
للعيد وربنا يطمن الناس اكثر واكثر ان شاء
الله
عن القوات المسلحه
والدعم السريع
يرجع لصوت العقل ويحفظ دماء الشعب
السوداني الحمد لله عمنا البلد امنه
والناس كلهم يعني في شغلهم عادل هنا يومين
ثلاثه الحمد لله رب العالمين نحن رسالتنا
ربنا يصلح ذات البين اي ناس مختلفين مع
بعض يسووا امور يسووا مع بعض يتفقوا عشان
ما يضرروا المواطن المواطنين دول ناس
تعبانين الناس عايشين عيشه صعبه جدا جدا
يقول الحمد لله على السلامه والهم يستتبها
وربنا يقوي جيشنا ويدينا الصحه والعافيه
وكل سنه وانتم طيبين
الحيه عاده الحياه الحمد لله وما في عوجه
والحمد لله
خير والله الاشتباكات الاخيره والعمليات
العسكريه كانت فقط في محيط مطار مروي
والقاعده العسكريه اما محليه مروي والقرى
التي تحيط بها فقد كانت بعيده عن هذه
الاشتباكات ويبدو ان حاله الهدوء تسيطر
على المكان داخل هذه المحليه نزار
البغداوي لقناتي العربيه والحدث من داخل
محليه مروي الولايه الشماليه
فمراسلان قبل قليل في الخرطوم ومروي يعاني
السودانيون من ازمه نقص مياه الشرب
وانقطاع الكهرباء فالاشتباكات تاتي تزامنا
مع ارتفاع درجات الحراره وزياده الاستهلاك
ما ينذر بكارثه انسانيه وشيكا
القتال لا يتوقف في السودان لكن خدمه
المياه والكهرباء توقفت ازمه انسانيه
خانقه تلح في سماء البلاد اجزاء واسعه
بالاحياء السكنيه في العاصمه تعاني شحا
شديدا في مياه الشرب بعد نقص الامداد
المائي من المحطات المزوده محطات المياه
الرئيسيه بالعاصمه تعرضت لاضرار بالغه
جراء الاشتباكات الازمه تفاقمت اكثر مع
ارتفاع درجات الحراره وزياده استهلاك
المياه في شهر رمضان اما انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي فبات عاديا وحكايه مالوفه
وان عاد برزت مشكله توقف شراء الخدمه من
التطبيقات البنكيه
على طاوله العشاء اجتمع ليلا وفي ساحه
القتال تواجه صباحا هذه التفاصيل الساعه
الاخيره قبل انزلاق السودان الى الصراع
بين البرهان وحماتي وفق صحيفه
ضجيج اليات العسكر لم يهدا لخمسه ايام مضت
لكنه تسلل من ليله هانئه شهدت عشاء اخيرا
بين الجنالين هدوء ظاهري اخفى تحت الطاوله
مخططات جاهزه للتحشيد واطلاق رصاصه الاولى
طرفات صراع قطع وعودا وقدمات تنازلات
بحضور وسطاء بهدف نزع فتيل التنافس بينهما
وفق صحيفه نيويورك تايمز وفيما كانت
الالات العسكريه المتنافسه تستعد للقتال
تدفقت القوات بهدوء على معسكرات الجيش
المتنافسه في جميع انحاء العاصمه الخرطوم
بدايه الخلاف وبحسب الصحيفه خرجت من قلق
حمد المتمثل باختراق الجيش من قبل موالينا
للنظام السابق فيما بدات المخابرات
العسكريه بقياده البرهان في اخبار
المسؤولين الاجانب بان حمدي حاول سرا
استيراد طائرات مسلحه من دون طيار من
تركيا لتعزيز قوته فالخلافات لوحدت حتى
بين افراد الجيش والدعم السريع الذين
تعاملوا كقوتين متنافستان وليس منسجمتين
ضمن نفس الدوله لكن ما ادى الى تفاقم
الخلاف اكثر محاوله الاتفاق على دمج
القوتين في جيش واحد خصوصا ان هذه العمليه
ستخرج حمدتي الخاسره الاكبر منها
الانقلاب على الاتفاقات لم يكن الاول في
تاريخ الطرفين ففي عام 2021 فاجا
الجنرالان مبعوثه الامريكي جفيف حين سقطت
الحكومه المدنيه في مسار الطريق السودان
الى الديمقراطيه عقبات كثيره وامال
الوسطاء بالتوصل لاتفاق صعبه بعد ان فجر
كل من الطرفين نواياه بوجه الاخر اياد
حمود العربيه
وينضم الينا من لندن الكاتب اسعافي خالد
الاعسر اهلا بك سيد خالد يعني هناك مبادره
للقوى الوطنيه السودانيه
هل لها دور في هذه المرحله هل للاحزاب
المدنيه داخل السودان دور يعني اقوى من
اصوات الاشتباكات التي تعلو منذ سته ايام
تحيه لك لمشاهدكم الكرام الواقع ان
الاحزاب المدنيه
هي كانت جزء اساسي في تعقيدات المشهد
الحالي وبالتالي ما لم يعني تعود الى
صوابه في البدء قبل ان تبادر
لتلعب دور الوسيط عليها ان تقر بالاخطاء
التي وقعت فيها ابتداء هذا التصعيد الذي
تم بين المكونه العسكري فيما بين الدعم
السريع وقوات الجيش هو في الاساس خلاف بذر
وبدا ظاهرا بعض ما جاءت فكره الاتفاق
الايطالي حتى نقوم موضوعين ولكن قضيه دمج
القواطيه لم تكن
بهذا التعقيد قبل ان تدرج كمحور اساسي في
الاوراق الخمسه التي تعطلت من الاتفاق
الايطالي وتم تداوله في قاعه الصداقه
بعيدا عن وجود المؤسسه العسكريه
ومن المهم هنا الاشاره الى فكره تمسك قوات
الدعم السريع العالم بالمبدا ان يتم الدمج
بعد عشره هنا تتداعى العديد من الاسئله
لماذا عشره اعوام ولماذا التفكير في يعني
امتلاك اسلحه نوعيه ولماذا التفكير في
اقامه مطارات القضيه اكبر من الاحزاب
المدنيه القضيه قضيه كل الشعب السوداني
وحتى المتعاطفين والداعمين للمبادئ التي
كانوا الشعارات التي كان يتمسك بها محمد
حمدان دوجلو في فترات شامله قبل تاريخ هذه
المعارك التي اندلعت الان ليسوا على تعاطف
مع مواقفه لانه مواقف الرماديه ولكن بعد
حصول هذه
الاشتباكات العنيفه والسلاح بين الطرفين
بمستويات عاليه وثقيله هل الموضوع فقط هو
الان يعني دمج او عدم دمج لانه اذا اردنا
الحديث عن حل وسط يقبل به البرهان او
حماتي هل نتحدث عن الفصل بين القوات ام
انسحاب حمادتي الى مراكزه السابقه
انا انا استطيع ان اقول لك كلام وانا
مسؤول منه حتى دعوه عشان التي تحدثت عنها
انا استطيع ان اقول لك ان محمد حمدان
دوجلو في هذه الجلسه عرض على البرهان
وعندما سالوا البرهان هذه بمعلومات يعني
عندما صار الدهان ماذا تريد ولماذا الدمج
متى كم تريد شخصا زمنيا للدمج رد محمد
حمدان دغله للبرهان اني اريد عشره اعوام
رد قائلا انه لن يحدث هذا هذا لن يحدث
وبالتالي انا استطيع ان اقول لك ايضا
اضافه انا اعلم ان هناك خلافات طويله بين
الب
طيره وساعه العديد من ابناء الوطن
الحاجبين على مصلحه واستقرار السودان
بعياديه
ولكن بيكون اسف وكان واضحا جدا من مواقف
محمد حمدان دوبلو غايه الدعم السريع في
الاونه الاخيره قال له حتى لا جلوس
الوسطاء الذين غادروا من نفسه وهناك
اتصالات تمت مع دوائر ضيقه
من من الاصدقاء ومن معارف ومن اهل محمد
حمدان دوبلو وهم يستطيع ان يخرجوا لينفوا
هذا الحديث ولكن
محمد محمد
ولكن الان البرهان يضع شرطا بانه لا حوار
قبل عوده احمدتي الى اتفاق ديسمبر اي
خروجها خارج
حدود الخرطوم وبالتالي اذا تمسك حمايه
بمراكزه وبما يريده الى اين ستذهب الامور
هل سنذهب الى حرب اهليه
نحن في السودان كلنا على قلب رجل واحد
المؤيدين لفكره الدمج والمعارضين لفكره
يعني الامد الزمني والاطفال والصغار جميعا
المتفقون حول فكره الدمج لا نريد
حول فكره السلام
لا نريد تصعيد لهذه الازمه لا نريد لوطنا
ان ندخل في خضم حروب لا نريد ان تنزلق
الامور ولكن يجب التفكير مرارا وتكرارا ان
ما هي الدواعي التي تدفع قوات هي اصاله
اسست لحمايه الشعب السوداني لكي تعوس في
الارض فسادا وتتحرك داخل المدن وبين
الاطفال وتجعل من النساء والمرضى
والمستشفيات جميع بشريه في عمليه عسكريه
يعني تضرر منها الشعب السوداني على الاخ
محمد حمدان دوبلو ان يغلب صوت العقل
لما كان يرفع من شعارات بانه رجل حاذف على
الانتقال السلمي السلس وانه رجل يريد ان
يؤسس الديمقراطيه في السودان علي ان يتمسك
بهذه الشعارات انا لا دفاعا على البرهان
انا اتحدث من زاويه السودان الوطن الذي
همنا جميعا هذا الذي يحدث الان هو فوضى في
اي دوله في العالم يمكن ان توجد قوات
تطالب تدمج في المؤسسه العسكريه
من قيام النظام الانتقاء الانتخاب
الديمقراطي وفي نفس وفي نفس الوقت هي
تتحدث عن كلمه سيد خالد ابقى معي سننوه
الى الاخبار العاجله نقلا عن اعلام مجلس
السياده الذي يقول بانه البرهان بحث مع
وزيره خارجيه السعوديه وامريكا فرص الحوار
بالسودان وايضا انه البرهان بحث مع قاده
عده دول اخرى اقليميه وغربيه الوضع هناك
بما انك تحدثت عن التفاصيل التي وردت في
تقرير فاين انشال تايمز دعنا نتابع
التصريحات التي قالها الطرفان للصحيفه
مواجهه البرهان واحمد العسكريه بارض
المعركه يقابلها تنافس اعلامي لا يقل حده
وفي وقت اكد احمد عدم التراجع عن اهدافه
على اعتبار ان ارض المعركه ستحدد كل شيء
لفت البرهان الى خروج جزء كبير من قوات
احمدتي عن السيطره قائد قوه الدعم السريع
اعتبر ان البرهان ليس مستعدا للانتقال
للحكم المدني لكن الاخيره اكد استئناف
الانتقال للمسار الديمقراطي بمجرد هزيمه
احمد
اهداف احمدتي تشمل اعتقال البرهان
ومحاكمته اهداف تبين محاوله الدعم السريع
الاستيلاء على السلطه وفق البرهان حمدتي
شدد على عدم معارضه دمج قواته بالجيش من
حيث المبدا الجيش اكد الالتزام باستكمال
العمليه السياسيه وفق الاتفاق الايطالي
ترشق كلامي يستكمله احمدتي بتاكيد انفتاحه
على وقف اعمال العطف لكنه يؤكد ايضا ان
البرهان لن يتوقف فيما يتهم قائد الجيش
قوه حميتي باعمال نهب في الخرطوم ودارفور
اذا من جديد السيد خالد احمد يريد اعتقال
البرهان كيف تصف رفع سقف هذه المطالب وهذه
التصريحات
انا في تقدير ان هي نوع من رقص رفع سقف
المطالب لخلق مساحه وحيز واسع للتفاوض
ولكن انا لازلت على امل وعلى قناعه بان
الفريقين الان ليس امام خيار
التفاوض وسوى ان يتذكره بان هذا السودان
ليس للبرهان وليس وانما هناك اسر وحاله
معاناه كبيره يعيش الشعب السوداني وهذه
ربما تكون بدعه لتغليف صوت العقل لا احد
في السودان يريد ان تنشف حرب اهليه الجميع
يدعون وقف اطلاق النار ونحن على ايام يعني
دينيه وروحيه يفترض ان يكون الناس في هذه
الايام
على مشارفه ابتداء رحله فرح واعياد وتبادل
العفو وهذه اشياء وقيم موجوده ومغروسه في
المجتمع السوداني انا في تقديري انه يجب
الناي من فكره المصالح الشخصيه الخاصه
التي يزعم بعض لتنفيذها عبر مظلات العمل
السياسي وهذا الخلطه الذي وقع يعني ابتدات
حديثك حول فكره الوساطه من القوى المدنيه
القوه المدنيه هي التي
هذا الحريق
في عام 2013 وتم يعني اعاده تبعيتها
للقوات المسلحه في 16 يناير 2017 العلاقه
ظلت هادئه وفي تناغم حتى بعد غياب الثوره
كان البرهان وعملتيه على تناغم كبير ولكن
ما ان جاءت فكره الدستور الانتقالي الذي
طرحتنا غابه المحامين السودانيين
والتبلوره الفكره الى الاتفاق الايطالي
وادرجت ماده الدمج القوات الا وكانت هذه
المعرفه الكلاميه والسيال الذي انتهى الى
بنود ومقترحات تتيح للدعم السريعا يبقى
خارج مظله المؤسسه الام
ريطانيا تعلمين هل اصبح الرجلان احمد
والبرهان عبئا على الشعب السوداني يعني
وعلى القوى المدنيه فعلا ان تتسلم مقاليد
الحكم لانه يعني نشاهد ماذا يحصل
السوداني خرج في ثوره عظيمه جدا كان موحد
وعلى قلب رجل واحد لكي يحقق الانتقال
السلم السلس ولكن يعني لازم نحن حتى نداوي
هذه الجراح يجب ان نكون شفافين للحد
البعيد كان يجب ان تقوم حكومه انتقاليه
باجل زمن معلوم وهي لا تكون مسيسه حكومه
من تكون مستغلين وعلى نفس التجارب التي
تمت في السودان على ان تقوم الاحزاب
بالعوده الى دورا وترتيب اوطائها وتوزيعها
والعوده للانتخابات ولكن الذي حدث ان هناك
فريق صغير من قوه حزبيه صغيره
وحكمت في مرتين منذ عام 2019 استطاعت ان
تمرر اجنداتها عبر ما يعرف في السودان
بالجداد الالكتروني الغرف الالكترونيه
المصنوعه شكرا حمدوك هذه الشعارات التي
رفعت نحن نعلم ان هناك غرف ملايين
الدولارات انفقت لكي خلق واقع غير حقيقي
على المشهد في
الارض عدد قوات الدعم السريع
وروج هو
ليس يستطيع ان اقول لك كذلك يعني نحن لا
نريد ان نساعد الاشياء
اكاذيب خدعه كبيره تمريره لا يجب ان تمر
نحن في مرحله خطره جدا من التاريخ اما ان
يكون هذا السودان او لا يكون كيف يكون
وهناك من يريد ان يدخل الاسلحه الى
السودان كيف يكون هناك من يريد لهذه
الدوله ان تكون سلطته غايبه وليست تناقي
اراده وطنيه حره كيف يكون هناك تدخلات
يتحدى البعيد
السوداني يعني يتخيل من التدخلات الدوليه
ومستوى حد الاستياء من انفراط السياده
الوطنيه التي غارت اذا نحن نتحدث هنا على
حزاب سياسيه يعني اراده نفسها خارجيه
وتريد ان تصطف بخلق الزراعه عسكري جديد
وان تحكم الشعب السوداني العشره اعوام
قادمه في وجود راسين في الدوله في وجود
قوتين
الجيش والاخرى الدعم السريع وهذا لا يمكن
ان يحدث لا توجد دوله في العالم وفي الكره
الارضيه بما فيها بريطانيا ام الديمقراطيه
في العالم وامريكا وكل بلدان الجمهور لا
توجد دوله فيها ديموقراطيه في اي جيشين لا
توجد دوله فيها انشغال فيلم سلس وفيها ال
عسكريه بغضبين وبراسين لا توجد ضوء هذه
افكار خاطئه يجب ان تنتهي خاصه خاصه اننا
بالغنا مرحله التصحيح وليس اسوا من الحرب
الا الحرب نحن الان بصدد التصحيح يتطلب
تقديم تنازلات الرجوع الى القوانين
المنظمه النائب بالفكره ادنى عسكره العمل
الحزبي المدني والنعي من محاوله خلق
التحالفات مدنيه عسكريه لك
لحاله
ببعض المصالح الشخصيه والرغبات الذا
تيه خالد الاعسر من لندن شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا مشاهدينا يا كاد ينتهي اليوم السادس
للمعارك في السودان وحتى الان لم يظهر
قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقله
بشكل علني كما ان قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح
البرهان
ظهر لمره واحده في مقطع قصير من احد غرف
العمليات
على مدار ايام سيطر اسمان على المسامع عبد
الفتاح البرهان قائد الجيش السوداني ومحمد
حمدان دقلو حميدتي قائد قوات الدعم السريع
القوات التي تخضع لكل منهما تخوض معارك
محتدمه في شوارع الخرطوم احتراب اندلعت
شرارته الاولى يوم الخامس عشر من ابريل
ولا تزال راحه دائره
تساؤلات تتنامى مع تطور المواجهه لعل
ابرزها لماذا يتجنب الخصمان الظهور لا احد
يمكن ان يجزم بمقر اقامه الخصمين خاصه ان
كل طرف يصر على الحسم فهي معركه وجوديه او
صفريه بقاء احد الطرفين يعني ان الاخر خرج
من المعادله السودانيه
عصر اليوم الاول من المعارك
ظهر البرهان في الخرطوم لخمسه عشره ثانيه
في مقطع مصور يرجح ان يكون التقط داخل
احدى غرف العمليات العسكريه من مقر
القياده العامه وبجواره قائد الحرس
الرئاسي ومجموعه من العسكريين يتابعون
الاحداث المشتعله ثلاثه اماكن قد يوجد
فيها البرهان داخل الخرطوم اما في قصر
الضيافه او القصر الجمهوري او القياده
العامه للجيش وهي الاماكن التي حاولت قوات
الدعم السريع السيط عليها وفي السابع عشر
من ابريل قصفت قوات الجيش احد المقرات في
حي المطار حيث رجحت القوات المسلحه وجود
قائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان حمدتي
تقارير اخرى تشير الى ان دارفور قد تكون
ملاذا امنا في حال استمرت المعارك حيث
يتمتع هناك بنفوذ وسيطره ربما لا يتوفران
لديه في الخرطوم يكتفي كل من البرهان
وحميتي بالحديث الى وسائل الاعلام هاتفيا
وعلى مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ينقل
البرهان تصريحاته نصا عبر الصفحات الرسميه
للجيش السوداني بينما يلجا الى النصر عبر
حساباته على تويتر وفيسبوك
[موسيقى]
ومن الخرطوم ينضم الينا المحلل العسكري
الفريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين اهلا بك سيد
فتح الرحمن يعني بعد سته ايام من
المواجهات مع قراءتك
لموازين القوى على الارض لمن هي لصالح
الجيش ام لقوات الدعم السريع
طبعا يعني مؤكد جدا انه موازين القوه
التمييز لصالح القوات المسلحه السودانيه
حيث انها هي القوه الاساسيه وهي الجسم
الاكبر وهي القوات النظاميه ذات الارث
التليد والتجارب العميقه وتدعم سريعه
انشاتها القوات المسلحه نفسها يعني لم
تاتي من جهه اخرى
مسلحه تعرف يعني كيف يمكن ان تقاتلها
وبالتالي انا اعتقد اصلا للحديث عن ان
هنالك فرصه للدعم السريع في ان يتغلب على
الغد الان بعد سته ايام يعني
الاشتباكات تحصل ولا اخبار دقيقه عن سيطره
القوات الدعم السريعه او حتى الجيش على
مراكز القوه الكبرى نتحدث عن مركز القياده
العامه عن القصر الجمهوري وايضا المطار
يعني دائما ما هناك اخبار
وتضارب بالمعلومات
ونؤكد لك المطار سيطره القوات المسلحه
السودانيه تماما القياده العامه هي مقر
اداره العمليات هذه وهي قياده الجيش
وبالتاكيد هي تحت سيطره القوات المسلحه
بنسبه 100% اما طائر صحيح
السيطره عليه مشتركه ما بين الجيش والدعم
السريع وذلك بسبب وجود حي المطار المتاخي
مباشره للمطار والذي
تتجمع فيه قوات كبيره من الدعم السريع
وتتخذ سكان هذا الحي تروح بشريه
تحتمي خلفهم من تدخل القوات المسلحه
السكان كامل السكان من حي المطار
لا ابدا السكان موجودين الدروع البشريه
اخلوا بعض النكات صحيح اخلوا بعض النساء
اخذوا بعض الاطفال
بشريه هم شخصيات يعني مسؤوله في الدوله من
يسكن حي المطار هذا يجب ان يكون من موظفي
الدرجه الاولى في السودان يعني اساتذه
الجامعات الكبار وقياده القوات المسلحه
الكبيره وكذا كل الرجال في هذا الحي
الدروع بشريه محتفظ بهم حتى لا يهاجمهم
الجيش في هذه المنطقه
وهذه المنطقه بينها وبين المدرج المطار
حوالي 20 او 30 متر فقط يعني مسافه قليله
جدا
وبالتالي هم يستغلون هذا الوضع يفرض يسيطر
على جزء من المطار ومن هذا
المكان القياده العامه من الاتجاه الشرقي
وهذا هو
لديهم عسكر واحد يعني عندما بدات هذه
العمليات
كان يسيطر على اكثر من 65 موقع داخل
الخرطوم الان لا يملك ولا موقع واحد من
هذه بخلاف موقع واحد فقط حتى نكون دقيقين
جوار منتزه الرياض مغر اداره العمليات
السابقا او هيئه العمليه السابقا هذا
المغر الوحيد
يحتفظ بالضباط الذين
اختطفوهم اسره وموجودين في هذا المبنى
مستخدما كثيرا وهذا ما يكبل يدات المسلحه
في ان تتعامل مع هذا الموقع في خلاف ذلك
لديه
سيد فتح الرحمن تمت الاستعانه بالطيران
طيران الجيش السوداني ولكن بحي المطار
بمركز القياده
وحول المطار هل لجا الجيش الى استخدام
الطيران لانه ذلك معروف بانه لا يمكن
استخدامه في ظل وجود السكان ومدن سكنيه
وهذا ما يطيل امد الازمه هذه
استخدموا الطيران صحيح في مروي واستخدم
الطيران في الخرطوم ولكن تخدم الطيران في
الخرطوم لمهاره عاليه جدا نحمد الله
سبحانه وتعالى السودانيه تتمتع بطيارين
ذوي كفاءه مهنيه عاليه جدا يعملون باحتراف
عالي جدا
غايه وفائره في الدقه تصيب الهدف وانا
اجزم ان الطيار اذا صوبنا هو هدفه واتضح
له في اخر لحظه ان هذا الهدف قد تصاب معه
جهه اخرى غير معنيه بالاصابه فيلغي
الاصابه ويلغي الهجمه كلها هذا هو هذه
التعبئه التي يعمل بها التيار السوداني
وانا يعني عندما يستخدمون الطيران في محيط
القياده العامه يستخدمون في الاجزاء
المفتوحه من القياده العامه التي تمكنهم
من اصابه اهدافهم بدقه دون
ان يتضرر اي
معني بالاصابه هذا هذه الناحيه يعني نطمن
المواطن السوداني في اي مكان عندما يشاهد
الطيران السوداني في السماء يطمئن ان هذا
الطيران لا لن يسبب له اذن وانما سيصيب
هدفه فقط اليوم استخدمت الطيران في تدمير
هداف تتبع للدعم السريع في كانت قادمه من
اتجاه ولايه وغادمه من اتجاه الولايات
دارفور كانت كلها اصابات دخيره جدا ودون
ان تحدث اي اضرار جانبيه شكرا جزيلا لك
المحلل العسكري الفريق فتح الرحمن محي
الدين حدثنا من الخرطوم
نترك الاشتباكات في السودان لدقائق ونتابع
معكم موجز لاهم الاخبار
تلقى وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحانه اتصالا هاتفيا من ناظره
الايراني حسين امير عبد الله تطرقا به
لعده موضوعات بين البلدين وناقشه ما تم
الاتفاق عليه اخيرا بين البلدين في الصين
وناقشه الخطوات المقبله لتعزيز العلاقات
بين السعوديه وايران
اكد الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي
يانستول تمبرغ اثناء الزياره الى كاف ان
اولويه الحلف تتمثل بضمان تغلب اوكرانيا
في الحرب على روسيا مضيفا ان مستقبل
اوكرانيا هو داخل العائله الاوروبيه
الاطلسيه وسيتم بحث خطه انضمامها للحلف
خلال القمه التي ستعقد في شهر يوليو
انا والرئيس هي مبادره دعم متعدده سيساعد
هذا على الانتقال من معدات ومبادئ حقبه
السوفياتيا الى معايير حلف شمال الاطلسي
وضمان العمل المشترك مع الحلف انها شهاده
على التزام النيتو طويل الاجل تجاه
اوكرانيا حلف شمال الاطلسيه يقف معكم
اليوم وغدا وكلما استدعى الامر ذلك
ان الوقت قد حان لدعوه كيف للانضمام الى
حلف شمال الاطلسي واتخاذ القرار المناسب
وشدد زيلينسكي لدى لقائه ستولتنبرغ في
كييف على ضروره ان تدعم كل الدول في
الناتو انضمام اوكرانيا الى صفوفه
نحن لا نعد بديلا لعضويه النيتو ولا نفكر
في حل وسط انا لا اقول هذا لمجتمعنا الان
لانه على ما اعتقد يدرك ذلك بوضوح انا
الان اقول هذا لقاده هؤلاء البلدان التي
تبحث باستمرار عن حل وسط عضويه اوكرانيا
المستقبليه في النيتو سنكون في الحلف
نعتقد ان هذا ضمان لامن اوكرانيا
وبتسامن مع اولى جولات الرئيس الفرنسي بعد
قانون رفع سن التقاعد تجمع حوالي 250 شخصا
في جنوب غرب فرنسا للاحتجاج على سياسه
قلمكرو انه مستعد للحديث مع معارضي قانون
رفع سند التقاعد الذي تم تمريره الشهر
الماضي
اذا كانوا مستعدين للتحدث نحن جاهزون لكن
اذا كان الهدف فقط هو طرح مزيد من المشاكل
واحداث الضوضاء فهذا لا يستحق كل هذا
العناء لذلك سنرى كيف ستسيل الامور اولا
شهدت مطارات هامبورج ودوسلدو وكولونيا في
المانيا اضرابات من قبل عناصر الامن وذكر
بيان صادر من الجمعيه الالمانيه للموانئ
الجويه ان الاضراب سينتج عنه الغاء حوالي
700 رحله جويه في المطارات الثلاثه خلال
اليوم وغدا مضيفه ان حوالي
45.2 الف مسافر الطروا الى تغيير خطط
سفرهم
نعود لتطورات الاشتباكات في السودان
وتتابع معكم هذه التغطيه الزميله ميسون
الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات